hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast 2016 and beyond reimbursement
and regulatory lessons for another year
named Judy O'Rourke of lab roots and all
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots we have a few important
announcements before we begin this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CME
button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credit this
webcast is designed to be interactive
then we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green su and a button at the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problems through the green two in a
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker renal wolf mhm
AVP for commercialization strategies
consulting and industry affairs that
decison incorporated his wolf is a
nationally recognized expert in the
field of laboratory commercialization
and reimbursement with over 20 years of
experience in the diagnostic laboratory
industry specializing in molecular
diagnostic laboratory she lectures
extensively on these topics and has
consulted for major laboratories and
laboratory associations throughout the
United States his wolf is a former
president and board member of the
California Clinical Laboratory
Association and is an active participant
with the ACL a the American clinical
laboratory Association and the
personalized medicine coalition she also
advises and presents to investor
audiences prior to joining lifan in 2009
his wolf healthy position of vice
president of reimbursement and
regulatory affairs that actually Oh
biotech and she has also held executive
positions in the area of
commercialization and reimbursement and
redpath integrated pathology genome
health and esoteric snell labcorp her
complete bio is found on the labyrinth
website I will now turn it over to miss
Wolfe for her presentation thank you
Judy and good morning or good afternoon
as the case may be so fasten your seat
belts at 2015 was challenging and 2016
is looking like it's going to be more of
the same and probably then some so if
you have your favorite psychic or other
sphere they are also struggling with
trying to deal with the uncertainties
that we're all facing on so many issues
and those issues include but probably
not exclusive to the protecting access
to Medicare Act a whole new coding and
coverage paradigm for toxicology and
drugs of abuse testing once again the
specter of FDA regulation next-gen
sequencing or as the cpt codes or
reference genomic sequencing procedure
codes gsps and advanced diagnostic tests
are in the forefront a lot of activity
on the commercial payers side around
reimbursement and especially compliance
audit activity is extremely heavy and
increasing both on the public and the
commercial payer side and definitely
this is the year of data so your
financial management systems and your
ability to aggregate and utilize data is
becoming increasingly important to your
success for many many reasons
the first one of course is for pama as
many of you probably know Pamela or the
projecting access to Medicare Act is a
means by which CMS is hoping to align
what they are paying for those tests on
the clinical lab fee schedule with what
they're saying will be market-based
pricing and in order to do that at some
point in in time all what they're going
to be deeming applicable laboratories
and the definition of an applicable lab
is still in question we'll need to
report a number of data points around
the payment levels and allowable levels
that they're receiving from non-medicare
pairs now originally the implementation
date for pama was set at january first
2017 and that was based on an initial
reporting period of the first half of
zoos near the second half of 2015 that
would have been reported sometime during
the first quarter of 2015 needless to
say we are now at April fixed the first
quarter of two thousand sixteen is
history and we still don't know truly
what the definition of an applicable
laboratory is and especially if more
hospitals then were originally defined
in the draft rule would be reporting
which could have a positive impact on
where the prices ultimately land we
don't know exactly what data points we
will need to submit nor do we know
exactly what the mechanism will
for submitting them so we have seen you
know requests for delay and I'll go into
that a little bit later however clearly
this gives us an extended opportunity to
prepare for when we do have to submit
this information to CMS also if we are
performing essays for which we need to
make a case for value-based pricing
we're going to have to have the
documentation to support that our
laboratory data as far as utilization
and potentially outcomes is valuable in
and of itself the ability to consolidate
different types of clinical information
and do you know that benefits management
and decision support is becoming more
and more crucial and of course to to
make the case for care coordination
multidisciplinary approaches and
tracking the cost of care and what works
and what doesn't work in this day of
accountable care organizations and other
bundling initiatives is increasingly
important so as I said obviously there
has to be an implementation delay at
this point because we've not seen the
final panel pama rule which will
hopefully give us some answers to the
questions that i just mentioned what is
an applicable lab exactly what needs to
be reported and how will we do it
because this is a rule that was passed
by Congress CMS can
just arbitrarily issue a statement of a
formal delay any modifications in the
implementation timeline will have to be
included in the next iteration of the
rule likely to be a final rule that we
see at a meeting that I was at yesterday
Maura Clark's teen who's the director of
ambulatory services where pama resides
at CMS indicated that they're working
very very hard on it he would hope to
have something that we can respond to
when we have the annual stakeholders
meeting in July but beyond that he could
not commit to a date as to when we would
actually see this final rule the
American clinical laboratory Association
proposed a one-year delay which would
mean a 2018 implementation date and the
National independent laboratory
Association proposed a two-year delay
which would give us a 2019
implementation date either way the good
news is that as part of Pama there was a
moratorium on price cuts until
implementation so potential which was
supposed to go through 2016 so
potentially this could mean that we have
some price protection for another
another year but we don't know for sure
until we see the timing on that final
rule and we are in a real period of
uncertainty that is impacting the VC
community
investors in this space where we saw
some statistics presented by piper
jaffray just yesterday where investment
in this space is really down and the
reason is not because there isn't a
belief of the incredible clinical value
that these tests provide but because
we're in just in such an uncertain
environment as far as you know exactly
what Tama will do to pricing will the
FDA pull the trigger on a final guidance
this year and many other issues so the
door is slightly slightly open for
another iteration of a draft rule for
stakeholders comment however if we see a
final rule it will still be based on CMS
processes the opportunity to comment so
this year saw some significant changes
in drugs of abuse coding and testing
those of you who are in this space may
remember that for 2015 the AMA had
created i believe it was 63 new cpt
codes for drugs of abuse testing and CMS
was concerned that those codes although
they admitted they were extremely
well-written could still lead to over
utilization so they created some g codes
and in most cases ran fairly parallel to
the AMA CPT codes however beginning this
year they took an entirely different
approach and this was based on one that
was started by palmetto GBA when
are instead of allowing for submission
and payment of individual drugs or drug
classes they have created codes that for
both presumptive and definitive testing
that group drug classes into these new
codes and so there will be a price paid
for the group code as opposed to
individual codes so the prices that you
see in parenthesis were the prices for
these new codes that were actually
proposed back on September 25th and then
we were able to make the case to CMS
that those codes were far too low and
often were below the cost of running
these tests and so we were able to
negotiate a quite significant
improvement in the pricing levels for
these codes and remember again these are
especially for the definitive tessa's
these are drug classes not individual
drugs but what's really important I
think especially if you are not in this
particular testing space is that in my
view this is you know further
substantiation of CMS is commitment to
bundling and looking at areas where they
feel there may be over utilization and
coming up with potential coating
solutions that they believe would help
with that also this whole area of a blts
or advanced diagnostic laboratory test
is one that is specifically called out
in the pama legislation and one of the
additional clarifications that we're
waiting for in the final pamo rule is a
hard and fast definition
of an a blt and these tests would be
eligible for some specific pricing
considerations initially CMS has been
struggling with this concept of the
algorithmic component of AD LTS and what
clinical value those algorithms actually
bring to the test and of course for
those of us that are familiar with this
area of testing those are truly the
heart of a DLP s.a.d lt's will be
required underpant under pana to have
their own specific CPT codes and a
number of labs that are performing these
tests formerly known as the MA you know
the multiple analyte assays with
associated algorithms and years ago
known as IDDM IAS did come forward
proactively and request and receive
category 1 CPT codes and then when the
first pama advisory panel meant they met
there was some lack of communication and
CMS interpreted their guidance as
pricing these tests by crosswalk which
of course is very difficult because of
these proprietary algorithms and so
therefore again on September 25th we saw
some very very painful proposed price
cuts up to as much as ninety percent of
the previous gassville prices that knows
those prices were fortunately rectified
and CMS acknowledged that the
appropriate way to price these tests was
through the gaps of process and so when
we saw the final fee schedules in
november of last year they were back up
to
where the contractors had originally
priced them but again we're still
waiting for a final definition of an ad
LT which does include these proprietary
tests with the algorithms and also at
this time anyway those tests that are
FDA cleared so as I mentioned those
tests that meet the definition of a navy
LT will be required under pana to have
very specific codes so the AMA has come
forward with a parallel proposal to
provide codes at least for the first two
years of commercialization while a test
is on building up its case to get a
category 1 cpt status not only clothes
for ad LTS but also for CDL teas or you
know clinical diagnostic laboratory
tests that are not otherwise described
by existing CPT codes so the editorial
panel has authorized a new section in
the in the seat feed schedule fee
schedule and in the code manual and we
are currently under discussion as to
exactly what this would look like and
what the process would be there will be
additional coverage discussion on this
at the editorial panel meeting next
month but again nothing can be
absolutely finalized from a coding
perspective until we see that final rule
from pama so the other new code coding
area that has become somewhat
controversial are these GSP or genomic
sequencing procedure codes and in the
past when companies were performing seek
sequencing procedures they would often
do an additional version of you know
stacking codes where they would select
the analytes specific codes which are
designed to be methodology agnostic that
were part of their panels and some just
submitting those codes that were
relevant to the patient's diagnosis even
if they were performed on a sequencing
platform and if the diagnosis code was
applicable and there was action ability
for those markers they had a really good
chance of getting paid now I think just
about every lab that or at least those
that we work with that are performing
these sequencing procedures understand
that this is really incorrect coding and
may even be considered up coding and
that they should be using these genomic
sequencing procedure codes where they're
testing meets these descriptors so
basically if you are performing a panel
sequencing panel that has a minimum of
five markers you are probably going to
need to be using these new sequencing
codes so I've just selected four of them
here because these are the four that
those contractors who have prices comes
and indicated that they would be
covering them in appropriate
circumstances you know have have chosen
to focus on and you can see the national
limit amounts are not nearly as high as
we had hoped that they would be or that
you know we believe they they should be
the basic cost structure and the cost of
running these tests is not necessarily
that of you know placing a specimen on
an honest on a sequencer it's all the
intellectual property that comes into
designing the panel and the
interpretation etc so this is where we
are now on the National limit amounts
for these tests when they are covered
and this is from this clinical lab fee
schedule of course the commercial payers
pretty much their reimbursement is you
know somewhat all over the map and
sometimes can be based on the CFS or a
percentage of the CFS but often can also
be based on the laboratories price but
we have seen some coverage progress with
this GSP codes the national government
services and NGS on a belief has now
finalized their draft for coverage for
non-small cell lung cancer palmetto GBA
and the mold x program also has you know
some some coverage for non-small cell
lung cancer and UnitedHealthcare a few
months ago posted there's which was
really the first commercial care that
we've seen do so and interestingly when
you may see in their policy references
what they believe makes a good credible
test that makes their standards they
reference that the test must be approved
by New York State and do not reference
the FDA and of course the first actual
contract that was issued under this
policy was for foundation medicine who's
asking
foundation one meets all uhv stated
criteria probably one of the most
exciting in my opinion coverage policies
that we've seen is a Cygnus for a whole
exome sequencing and this policy
actually acknowledges that there are
times we're either from a clinical
perspective or a cost perspective it
makes the most sense to perform the
whole exome sequence rather than
individual markers and they also are
requiring genetic counseling when these
tests are performed so again just
because this is definitely a year where
there's so much focused on compliance
and audits I encourage anyone who is
performing these tests to make sure with
a certified coder whether or not your
panels your tests actually fit the
descriptors for these GSP codes and to
use them when appropriate so definitely
whether there is a formal coverage
policy or not if you want to achieve
coverage on a claim by claim basis for
your sequencing you absolutely have got
to demonstrate why this test was
medically necessary for this patient why
the test was ordered and how the results
were actually used in managing that
patient and we can win appeals when we
have the documentation you know to prove
that that case we are also seeing
activity on behalf of the FDA on you
know moving forward to regular potential
regulation
of sequencing and interestingly they
have taken a very different approach
with a sequencing regulation in that
unlike what they have done with the
laboratory developed test guidances and
draft guidances they are having a wide
open dialogue with the industry and with
stakeholders that what makes sense for
sequencing regulation before they
actually release a draft guidance and so
you can feel that the atmosphere in the
room with these conversations is so much
friendlier for lack of a better word and
supportive than what we've seen at a
number of the ldt stakeholder meetings
so you have to applaud the FDA I believe
for taking this approach and we are
still facing a draft guidance on
laboratory developed test a good portion
of the industry is taking the stance
that if additional regulation or
oversight needs to occur for these texts
it should be done through rulemaking and
not through guidance so there are
actually four proposals on the table
right now in discussions with Congress
as to how to move this process forward
and these proposals run all the way from
the FDA draft guidance as you know
hopefully mitigated in response to
stakeholder comments which they've
received thousands to modernizing CLIA
hype hybrid model
there's a number of iterations out there
right now at the end of 2015 the SBA did
release a white paper which they
intended to help make the case for the
need for additional oversight of
laboratory develop tests unfortunately
the 20 examples that they use I think in
my opinion kind of backfired on them
they used you know Tess like Oncotype DX
which is extremely well respected and in
every guideline there were some tests
that are no longer on on the market so I
don't know that this whitepaper
healthcare case many of us would say
that it actually harmed it be that as it
may on a number of occasions Jeff shirin
from the FDA has indicated that it is
their intent to release this guidance in
2016 but he did admit that that doesn't
necessarily preclude the fact that we
might see some congressional action as
well and then for those of you that
remember the last time the FDA tried to
finalize the guidance for El DTS was
back in 2012 which was also an election
year and it never got out of OMB Office
of Management and Budget so the FDA is
required to give us 60 days notice of
their intent to release a final guidance
and needless to say we have not seen
that notice yet so big big issues that
we're facing is this issue of audit and
compliance and fraud
fraud act activity so the statistics are
somewhat all over the math of one of the
most recent that I've seen is that for
every dollar that the government spends
on anti-fraud activities they recoup you
know seven point seven dollars so this
is big business for them unfortunately
you can be considered guilty until
proven innocent and the burden on a
laboratory to defend itself from an
accusation even when that accusation
makes note makes no sense and is not
legitimate it's very very high and we're
not seeing the contractors zpics other
editors auditors held accountable for a
hearing to timelines to respond and the
administrative law judge appeals process
is seriously broken at this time we're
seeing a lot of zetec zonal contractor
activities where for laboratories that
they feel have engaged in fraudulent
activities they're suspending those
laboratories pecan numbers so that
secludes you from doing business and
offering your services for Medicare
beneficiaries and again you're guilty
until proven innocent and by the time
you have made your your case that there
was no fraud involved you could be out
of business so it's extremely important
that you have a a bona fide compliance
program that that is a living compliance
program that you train to
and managed to and you know protection
and being proactive on these things is
the best thing that you can do and just
cut some conversations with two of the
attorneys that we work with between them
they're currently managing six examples
of unprecedented suspense suspensions
and just to give you an idea some of
this these suspensions and activity that
we're seeing thing to be targeting
laboratories in the areas of
pharmacogenetic testing the state of
Florida and especially those
laboratories that utilize contracted
sales forces rather than w2 employee so
that's something that you really should
look at it is something that you are
currently doing or are considering they
we've also seen a recent finalization of
the Medicare overpayment rule which is
very specific as to your obligations to
return some potential overpayments
within 60 days and the OIG work plan for
2016 also has a lot of continued focus
on the clinical laboratory arenas we've
seen also in the last few years but I'm
very interestingly I'm going to skip ed
for a minute
is this Yates memo that was published
recently which speaks to the area of
personal responsibility so laboratory
owners executives can't any longer hide
behind the corporation and they are
being held personally responsible for
any fraudulent or non-compliant activity
and this is being done both on the
public side and on the commercial site
also it's not unusual to see
laboratories attorney shop until you
find an attorney who will give you a
legal opinion that aligns with what it
is that you want to do often around
these areas of patients shares of cost
and discounting and and waving
co-payments deductibles etc but now if
one of these agencies believes that
that's what you have done and you
thought multiple opinions and hanging
your hat on the one you like the most
they are pretty much throwing that
opinion out another area that's really
also under scrutiny especially with
Medicare is the areas of panels and
custom panels so be sure that if you do
have panels on your requisitions and
this has also become a huge area of
contention in those jurisdictions that
are under the mole vets program you know
make sure that you have physician
signatures authorizing these custom
panels and that your requisition is
designed in a way so that physicians can
clearly opt in or opt out of any panel
components
back so I think a really big issue that
is occurring is this ever-increasing
share of costs that patients have so
even if you're an in-network laboratory
which is becoming very difficult to
achieve these days and your service is
considered coverage it's highly likely
that there still will be a very
substantial patient share of cost
patients are seeing ever-increasing and
this is especially true under the health
exchanges but not exclusively to the
health exchanges you know deductibles
co-pays out of pockets that you must
make sure you manage your collection
processes on these years of costs in a
compliant manner and so we're seeing you
know laboratories that are creating
policies of discounting or what they say
routinely discounting or waving these
shares of costs and that has created a
lot of compliance problems and legal
activity so basically when you're
dealing with the commercial payers
documentation on both the financial side
and the medical necessity side is
becoming more and more critical we're
seeing increasing members of front and
we can request for additional
information you know exactly what
testing are you doing and why is it
medically necessary at the very front
end of the adjudication process before
the claim can proceed further so it's
very important that you educate your
clinician clients on the importance of
documenting this type of information and
that's for their benefit and
the benefit of their patients as well as
four hours also just because you get
paid doesn't mean that you're going to
keep it we see recoupment request an
audit requests going you know as far out
as you know 12 to 18 months from the
date of service or date of payment or
sometimes even more so as I'm sure you
all know as difficult as it is to get
medical records in a timely manner
around the data service think about
trying to get that information you know
18 months out so you know really this
training process and having a level of
assurance that should you need those
records that information on the clinical
utility for that patient and medical
necessity is there is very important
appeals work we encourage our clients to
avail themselves of those opportunities
however if you don't have that
documentation of medical necessity and
peer reviewed collateral to support the
use of the test for that particular
patient scenario it does more harm than
good to submit appeal that doesn't have
a chance to be paid because it just
reinforces the payers perception yet
these services should not be covered
also we're seeing tremendous
consolidation amongst pairs which also
exacerbates this narrow networks
situation and how difficult it is to get
in network status unitedhealthcare just
a couple of weeks ago published a policy
that they've actually put forward to
many of their physician providers in the
past which basically says that if you
are a non-participating laboratory and
you routinely wave or cap co-payments or
deductibles or other shares of cost your
claims will be considered
covered and you could potentially also
be you know at risk for prostitution
under the federal False Claims Act and
we still see so many laboratories having
these policies publishing these policies
leaving and materials behind with with
their physicians so please review your
policies on on this pairs mean business
we're seeing audits where the payers are
demanding to see that if there was a
patient share of cost that you did Bill
it and the only exception would be if
that patient was eligible and you have
the documentation to prove that for a
true bona fide financial assistance
program we're also now seeing
requirements for medical records that
are submitted on the front end for
claims that include not otherwise
classified or NOC code such as eight one
four seven nine and eight 1599 so again
this issue of documentation is a very
very important one also when the pair's
go to your websites which they do and
they see evidence that you have you know
cat the cost of your test they are
taking the stance that you have an SS
repriced the cost of that test and
they're coming back to you and saying we
don't want to see any more claims for
thirty five hundred dollars when you're
saying that the patient will never have
to pay more than a hundred dollars
that's now the new class of your test
and we're going to apply out-of-network
penalties when we do pay based on that
hundred dollars and seek recoupment for
claims that were paid
based on the larger list price so
they're very very serious about this and
again remember that Yates memo if you're
an executive and an officer it comes
back to you you are where the buck stops
even if these actions were the result of
non w to employees the payers take the
stance of follow the money you got paid
therefore you're responsible for any
actions or statements that resulted in
those claims coming in your door and
many of you have probably been following
the health Diagnostics case but in the
past when we have these discussions with
clients and they say show me the case
show me the fine show me the prison
sentence and it was hard to find them
because often these activities and since
were settled and then sealed but no more
and this is a very good example of what
can happen
right so with that um I will throw it
open to any questions and the best that
you may have thank you for that
informative presentation before we get
started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can we'll give you a moment sure to pose
questions
well if there are no questions today I
would once again like you think Reno
wolf for her presentation do you have
any final comments um just add you know
we're at a time where what we can do um
from a clinical perspective I'm a
personalized medicine perspective is so
incredible and we just have to work
together which lab industry sometimes
does not know it's known for doing to
come out with ways to resolve the issues
and concerns so that we can do things
like the vice president's moonshot to
cure cancer and all these personalized
medicine initiative so that they can
come to fruition so that we can begin to
attract a venture capital again and
achieve the goals that we're all trying
to and we did get some questions yes so
your first one is or Medicare payments
similar to insurance reimbursements so
often pans base their fee schedules on
the clinical lab fee schedule so you
know that could be a discount off where
the clinical lab fee schedule lands
which is one of the reasons that pama is
so significant um its best it's not
always a direct crosswalk as it were to
the CL SS especially when you are
performing proprietary testing where you
would want to hopefully be able to
negotiate a value-based price for your
service but
from a terminology perspective and
symetra exactly where you're going with
this question but Medicare payment is an
insurance reimbursement in the sense
that Medicare is the insurance for those
beneficiaries
when the FDA releases guidance on the
lab developed tests do you expect it to
just affect labeling and documentation
or will test validation also be affected
it will also affect test validation
because the FDA has what they call yoke
us our requirements or quality system
requirements and one of the biggest
argument for the need for additional
regulation is to ascertain that these
tests do have analytical validity in
other words are they actually testing
the marker that they say that they're
marking for that they're testing for
with appropriate levels of sensitivity
and specificity and also clinical
validity are they looking for the right
markers for that particular diagnostic
question well thank you again this was
an educational webinar and thus offers
free continuing education credits after
the webinar is over please click on the
CME button located in the bottom left
hand corner of your web page and follow
the process of obtaining your credits
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through October 6 2016
you will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
afford that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event to next time bye